welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
companion bonus worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 19 and we're gonna learn how to
develop a habit of reading I like to
read more than most kids I really like
to read a lot
I had edy gave me a copy of the World
Almanac and that was heaven to me and I
can still tell you that almost
population was 214 thousand and six in
1930 some numbers just kind of stick
with you and very early probably when I
was 7 or so I took this book out of the
Benson library called a thousand ways to
make a thousand dollars
and one of the ways in this book was
having penny weighing machines
[Music]
and I sat and calculated how much it
would cost by the first weighing machine
and how long it would take for the
profit but that one to buy another one I
would sit there and create these
compound interest tables to figure out
how long it take me to have a weighing
machine for every person in the world
first books that read on investment
we're actually in my dad's office pretty
soon I read all the books in the office
and read some of them more than once a
few years ago I went to Amazon and sure
enough they had this manual there so
well reliving my use other guys were
going to Amazon probably and and a fine
old playboys or something but I bought
old movies manuals instead and well I
got school I started selling stocks that
was 20 years old at the time and looked
about 16 and acted about 12 so I was not
the most impressive salesperson anybody
ever met but what I would do was a I
went through page by page looking for
possibly undervalued stocks I should
mention one thing about reading it was
at the library here at Columbia I wish I
spent probably more time than any other
soon
I lived there practically but then I
pulled the book out there have to be
who's an American that told me something
about my professor Benjamin Graham and
then I looked up and I went to the
library and I said I want to learn more
about this because I learned this over
here that changed my whole life
you know we owned I go now because of
that library and directing me to some
other book and then following through on
that now it's the chance I read about
one-fifth the pace
the bill does but I still spend five or
six hours a day reading I mean it just
you can learn so much I particularly
love biography just you know to be able
to live the lives of these people have
been extorted you can see them so
extraordinary the lessons and the you
know the discouragements they face just
everything about it so I did you can't
get enough of reading and I would say
reading is the strongest signal for
success in the future that I've ever
seen it is the strongest strongest
strongest I got my first job in radio
when I was 16 years old
because I've been in broadcasting and
I was 16 years old but my first job I
got because I was a great reader when
you are a great reader you can
articulate and speak and command the
English language in ways that other
people cannot and people think you're a
lot smarter than you are
lots of times because you're great
reader have you ever met a person who
was a great reader when they were young
who was not successful you never never
it is the absolute best foundation ever
in life how do you read one book a week
leaders are readers the challenges the
average person reads about two books a
year but the average CEO read about four
to six books a month so how do you get
to this point where you're getting to
one book a week one of the reasons why
I'm so excited about reading is because
if somebody has decades of experience
and they put it into a book and you can
sit down in a day or two and read that
book you can download decades of
knowledge in days right so you have such
a huge advantage so how do you read one
book a week without speed reading well
here's a secret look at the numbers
right when I went onto Amazon it and out
that the medium number of words per book
is about 64,000 words and the average
person like we teach speed reading all
around the world at 150 different
countries online the average person
reads about 200 words per minute so now
when you divide 64,000 words per book by
200 words a minute comes out to be about
320 minutes 300 20 minutes to get
through a book of 64,000 words but how
many words is that a day divided by
seven you get about 45 minutes a day
forty-five minutes our greeting a day
and you get through a one book a week
now that's much more manageable but
here's the secret is you have to
schedule it
you must schedule this time because if
you say all I'm gonna read here or there
it never really happens like it's more
of a dream or it's an interest but when
you schedule it it's in your appointment
book it's in your calendar this is time
for you it's like time you would have
with your boss or an investor or
somebody a family member something
that's so important that you would never
cancel on that I certainly was quite I
was very very focused I was reading all
the time so I see the reading working my
computer reading comics playing dungeon
dragons I can't think I understand
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy that
wonderful book by Douglas Adams that was
that there was a key book for you what
was it about that book that that fired
your imagination yeah so I guess when I
was in around 12 or 13 I had company
existential crisis and I was reading
Paris books on trying to figure out the
meaning of life and oh like what does it
all mean because it's brought it so it's
seeming quite meaningless and then my we
happen to have like some books by
Nietzsche and Schopenhauer in the house
which you should not read at age 14 it's
really negative so so but but they don't
then I read The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy it was like quite positive I
think and and it sort of highlighted the
important point which is that a lot of
times the question is harder than the
answer and if you can properly phrase
the question then the answer is the easy
part
and so the if to agree that we can
better I've sent the universe then we
know better know what questions to ask
and then whatever the question is that
most approximates to what's the meaning
of life and you know that that's that's
the question we could ultimately get
closer to understanding and so I thought
well to degree that we can
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness and if in knowledge here
knowledge then that would be a good
thing
I like the ography is in general
biographies I think are really you know
really interesting read done for them
well I think you learn a lot depending
upon you know whose life you're reading
about that there lots lessons in there I
read Isaacson's biography of jobs which
I thought was quite interesting and I
actually really liked I am his biography
of Benjamin Franklin who I would say
certainly one of my heroes you seem like
a really great guy
basically I sort of was thinking about
this when I went as a kid and trying to
find some meaning in life like what's
the meaning of life you know and I quite
sad about it actually when as a teenager
and then I read The Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy which basically said like
the thrill the Rope you know they
basically universe is the answer and you
just need to figure out the questions so
I think you know that that's if I can
help kind of figure out the questions
then that I've considered that to be
meaningful the fact that people argue
with me on this reading thing and people
argue with me about mentors know just
use your own gut feeling is that how you
learn English when you were two years
old you use your gut feeling to start
conjugating verbs no you learn from
other people you learn manners you learn
language you learn all things valuable
you learn to drive from another person
so it doesn't it make sense you learn
life so books are just the mentors who
maybe are dead now you want learn about
Steve Jobs you know live to teach you
but you can learn through accumulated
wisdom and that's what trust me I meet I
very few powerful businessman I've ever
met
don't read a lot Warren Buffett who I
think's the best businessman by far in
the world has done see has 75 companies
that he pretty much runs 200 billion in
revenue he reads eight hours a day
he reads 600 he said he slowed down in
his old age I only reads 500 pages a day
Bill Gates goes on reading vacations
Mark Zuckerberg just start started a
reading once a week book club on
Facebook and already got
a couple million fathers and now with
audiobooks there's no excuse you got
YouTube videos let this thing run in the
background like you want to become like
a super computer you just download smart
crap from smart people and you pick and
choose like some people or like Thai I
don't agree with everything you say I'm
like good I don't agree with everything
I said like a year later I'm like wait I
was wrong there is incredible and
indelible influence and imprinting going
on on your philosophy and on your mind
when you read a book so you have a
conversation with someone and I'm sure
you've had a conversation maybe it's
with a chef or a great entrepreneur or
wise human being and that maybe there
was just one conversation but that
person in that 10 minute conversation or
hour-long conversation said something to
you that formed your philosophy that
changed the rest of your life well
that's what you can get in a book you
can have a conversation tonight with
Kanye you can have a conversation
the next night with Edison you can have
a conversation two nights from now with
Nelson Mandela you can read the
biography that I recently read off Elon
Musk you know Rican you can read about
Steve Jobs you can read about Vincent
van Gogh's life you can read about
Martin Luther King Jr's life you can
read about the titans of industry and
what they went through and how they
innovated and how they dealt with
struggles and how they dealt with wealth
you can read books on productivity from
the most productive people on the planet
you can learn how people who build
companies like IKEA and Red Bull how
they did it they took a small idea and
built it into an empire so what I'm
suggesting to you with great love and
respect as I always do in these mastery
sessions is reading a book is nothing
more than having a conversation with the
author and you can spend your evenings
or morning's or afternoons or lunch
times connecting with the greatest minds
who have ever graced the planet you
cannot put a price tag on that read
right
read read if the president were here one
of his greatest strengths is reading
that's one of the reasons why he's a
good communicator why he's such a good
writer he's a voracious reader so we're
trying to get our girls no matter what
to just be to love reading and to
challenge themselves with what they read
and not just read the gossip books but
to push themselves beyond and do things
that maybe they wouldn't do so I would
encourage you all to to read read read
just keep reading and writing is another
skill it's practice it's practice the
more you write the better you get drafts
our kids are learning the first draft
means nothing you're gonna do seven ten
drafts that's writing it's not failure
it's not not the teacher not liking you
because it's all marked up in red when
you get to be a good writer you mark
your own stuff and read and you rewrite
and you rewrite and you rewrite that's
what writing is and if you come out with
those skills and then you're confident
and you can articulate and you can stand
up straight and look anybody in the eye
and say this is who I am it's a pleasure
to meet you that's one of the things we
try to do with our mentoring program
with young girls my message to them is
if you can walk into the White House and
meet the first lady and say my name is
how are you and look me in the eye then
there's nothing you can't do that's why
it's important if you guys walked here
are sitting here in front of all these
people standing tall asking questions
using your voice you have to practice
that these arenas just show up again and
again and then you just get used to it
the nerves go away and you start
relaxing into your own abilities but
it's practice you know I could always
get as many books as I wanted I could go
to the library you know I had a
grandmother who would would read to us
and it was you know it was thought to be
a great thing so early reading lets you
imagine all these situations
and start to think of yourself you know
could I ever run a business could I ever
discover something in science and I do
think some positive reinforcement hey
you you're clever you can do these
things at a young age takes you a long
ways and you know then this is a great
time to be a curious person I read very
eclectically like no book is is bad form
from entering the the book list but then
I tend to be extremely impatient about
the books I actually read I would begin
like 10 books and drop nine of them
after 10 pages it's not always the
wisest policy but it's my policy that if
a book didn't really teach me something
new had some interesting insight in the
first 10 pages the chances it will it
could be that in on page 100 there'll be
some mind-blowing idea that I am now
missing but there's so many I keep
thinking there are so many books out
wonderful books out there that I will
never read
so why was waste time on a less optimal
optimal book so I would try like a book
on biology and then economics and then
psychology and then fiction and whatever
and just go through them quite quickly
until I find something that really grabs
me one of my favorite thoughts from
Martin Luther King is if you want a new
idea read an old book well books many
different ones the bhagavad-gita is
probably one of my favorite books it's
it's been such a huge part of my
personal journey and personal life many
other religious texts as well so the
Bible has been a big part of my study
spent a lot of time with the Bible and
and then it can just be thoughts and
ideas even if the last 2,000 years so
stoicism a huge fan of Marcus Aurelius
meditations that's been a huge book for
me that I've studied and sometimes old
can just mean 50 years or a hundred
years ago too but those are some of the
bigger ideas that I think have had more
prominent effects in my life so Vedic
and stoic knowledge has probably been
the most influential
we gather information from other
people's life experiences in a very
unique way and it's one of the reasons
why people really enjoy autobiographies
it's one of the reasons why people
really enjoy truly reflective
introspective thinking because we we can
pick out little gems in ourself so even
though you might be talking in your
meditation book about things that other
people have talked about in meditation
books you're talking about it from your
unique personal experience and when
someone reads that or hears you say it
you get something intangible out of that
language I think is a big thing that I
didn't really come to until later in
life I think post-military
didn't read a lot there was like a
reading it wasn't really encouraged or
not initially encouraged like all these
books that my wife the read when she was
a kid and I just had no idea what they
were the books you were supposed to read
in high school like I never read yeah
yeah and and language just really wasn't
how people communicated in my family I
mean not to say anything bad about my
family they just it wasn't a very verbal
household and I could see a lot in them
and in people when I was in the military
the absence of language really made
people do crazy things and not being
able to express yourself made you know
that made I think child or can make
people you know angry aggressive and I
just saw many examples of that so when I
think when I found when I went to school
and for really the first time discovered
plays really because I would knew about
acting and place but I didn't write read
anything until I went to Julliard or
were you kind of like inundated with you
know all these great writers then then I
noticed in myself that for the first
time I was really to label the things
that were not right or were right or the
I wish I had the words for at the time
and you're in New York you're surrounded
by all these like really interested and
interesting people who
on the whole to generalize very you know
that's have an edge you know and are
around more culture so their language
it's something that's more like a tool
and a weapon and I wanted that and be
able to explain a lot of things that I
just can see how what a valuable thing
it is and so since then I've you know
really in love with language and you
know trying to consume as much as I can
I know there are ways that are
recommended to read a book so as to
extract the the actionable information
as quickly as possible from it I have
never been a an adopter of any of those
ways so like you know and I mean we're
still I basically read everything at the
same speed so I read everything like
it's Scripture so if it's you know you
know People magazine in a waiting room
of a dentist's office I'm reading that
at the same speed that I'm reading you
know a work of philosophy or
neuroscience and the big change of late
I mean the you know I guess this is
probably happened somewhere around 10
years ago is that once I realized that
there's functionally an infinite amount
of information to consume it was
doubling you know the science has every
three to five years and you know there
are literally thousands of good books
that I will wish I had read but I will
never get around to reading I've become
a very fickle reader in the sense that I
you know I've cut my losses very early
the sunk cost fallacy has completely
disappeared for me the idea that I've
you know spent five hours or five days
on this thing so I better just finish it
right that used to be my orientation
with respect to reading books now I'll
discard a book you know just on a whim
because I know there's an infinite
amount of stuff I want to read you know
I don't go into the table of contents
and look at the structure of the book
and then go to the index and then look
at the topics and then pay I mean I just
start on page one and start reading and
then when I get bored I stop you know
and so that's you know and do it do with
what do with that life hack what you
will I'll give you a funny story here my
teacher in Glendale High School if
you're listening and you're from
Glendale and you
to Glendale High School you need to go
and ask if anybody there knew a teacher
named mrs. Collins
okay miss Collins my gosh this woman
gave me nightmares we should read two
books that was then this is now and the
other one was up my sub man I don't know
if you guys read it as well nice goal of
my sub man was the Lenny you know he
would pet the rabbit and it would kill
him because he was so strong and so I
took this class and it was a girl
sitting in front her name was Carmen she
was one of the cheerleaders and I would
try to hide in front of this girl so
miss Collins wouldn't see me she would
say Patrick read the next paragraph oh
my gosh it was like the most
embarrassing didn't think about it this
way the entire day when I'd go to school
I had one dread you know what it was
Synnex period miss Collins is gonna ask
me to read in front of my thirty peers
right so I hated reading I couldn't
stand it I was a bad speller the whole
nine so I go into the army for me was a
math class when I was in a military I'd
get bored I'd go by a math analysis what
can I do for minutes because math to me
was very interesting because you're
figuring a life out you're figuring out
a formula and everything a life is math
if you look around everything in this
room this is purely a mathematical setup
room right and so all of a sudden I get
out of the army my sister recommends me
to book called how to win friends and
influence people my first boss from
Bally's recommends me how to master the
art of selling by Tom Hopkins and then I
read those two and then somebody
recommend me rich that poor that those
are my first three books and I said you
have got to be kidding me I feel like I
found a secret here are five books I
highly recommend let's start the first
one Bryan Holaday stillness is the key
you guys want to really learn how to
find stillness and all this uncertainty
and anxiety and stress and overwhelmed
this is a great book of the Stoics that
will teach you how to find that
stillness in yourself meditation
something I've been doing for a long
time was meditating back in high school
and college with sports learning about
visualization learning about calming the
mind breath work this is what we did if
athletes to become great athletes we did
it every single day in meditation
there's so many different forms this is
the philosophy behind it I was highly
recommend checking this
here's the second book let me know if
you've read this book the Prophet this
one is a spiritual classic with more
with millions of copies sold in 40
different languages since 1923
I recommend this one short one I like
short books because for me I'm a slow
reader so this is the second one the
Prophet make sure to check it out the
third one this is a goodie and a favor
to a lot of people but it's a practical
guide to personal freedom The Four
Agreements if you've read this one check
it out if you've read this one check it
out let me know
four agreements for me I've had to learn
the hard way many times about the four
agreements being impeccable be
impeccable with your word don't take
anything personally don't make
assumptions and always be your best
great book to learn why this is
important to check it out for agreements
are one McManis the way of the warrior
an ancient path to inner peace again if
you want to find inner peace during this
time of uncertainty and stress and
overwhelm the way of the warrior by my
friend Erwin McManus make sure to check
this book out really powerful the
warrior harnesses their strength it's
all about the lessons of the warrior and
you are a warrior my friend and this one
is a good one that a friend told me
about and I had no clue this was out
there but I read it in a set sitting and
it was really powerful
it's called rules for a knight I want
you to take this book out called rules
for a knight
yes it's by the actual actor Ethan Hawke
which I thought is he gonna have a good
book who knows but I'll tell you why
this is a cool book it's um it's about
some some papers that he found in a
basement and it was papers from a knight
from his ancestors who a night fearing
he may not return from battle writes a
letter to his children and attempt to
leave a record of everything he knows
that he'll never see them again and he
writes this letter to his kids so I
really liked this book Ethan
[ __ ] rule for a night for a night so
these are the five books check out these
books if you want to take a screenshot
real quick you can so you can have all
these now I've got a special bonus cup
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the best live
thirty questions of the day it's not
enough to just watch a video you have to
do something about it so pull out your
worksheets and answer these questions
and if you don't have the worksheets yet
get them for free by checking the link
in the description below here we go
question number one how can you schedule
reading into your calendar number two
what are the next five books that you
want to read and number three which
three people can you gift a book to join
you on your reading journey and if
you're doing the best live 30 challenge
with me put a hashtag best live 30 in
the comments below we want to celebrate
you if you want to change where you are
then you need to change who you are you
are a direct result of the environment
that you're in of the people that you
hang out with of the habits that you do
regularly and of the media and
information that you consume on a
regular basis you are where you are in
life because of your parents because of
your friends because of the books you
are reading or not reading because of
the Netflix shows or YouTube channels
that you are watching or not watching
and if you want to change where you are
in life you need to grow as a human
being you need to change who you are one
of the great great great advantages of
reading is that you get to take lessons
and it may have taken somebody else
decades to learn and they've consumed it
and they've written it into a book
decades sometimes of research and
knowledge that you can consume in a
couple of hours and immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
it's a cheap it's a hack and for a lot
of you you may not have a great circle
of friends you may not have the ability
to go out and network with people you
may live in a tiny town you may have
family that doesn't support you and so a
lot of you will then say well that's my
lot in life and I'm screwed and I can
never change that no you can change it
by reading write by reading you are
hanging out with people who've done a
lot more than you and the more that you
we're hanging around those people even
if they're not in front of you it'd be
amazing to have Tony Robbins sit with
you every single day and help guide you
through life but because you can't have
that you can have his books you can
learn from him you can apply all of his
lessons into your life on a daily basis
and start seeing growth and that applies
to any of the authors that you might
look up to I take this even a step
further in that as my video consumption
has gone up I've read less and less and
less I still read I'm not happy with how
much I'm reading I probably read a
couple of nights a week I try to make it
a daily practice so it's one of the
things that I'm working on but I consume
a ton of YouTube content I much prefer
watching videos than reading a book
that's where my mindset is that it's why
I make videos for you guys it's why I do
the top 10 series in the mentor me
series especially because I selfishly
mean I want to hang on people who've
done so much more than me and the more
that I'm hanging around those people the
more their mind sets their way of
thinking their attitudes their belief
seeps into me to allow me to go off and
do bigger things
Elon Musk and Tony Robbins and Mel
Robbins and et and all the people Warren
Buffett that I profile I feel like are
my friends like these are my
acquaintances these are guys and ladies
that are in my ear constantly pushing me
to do more to strive for greater things
because the people in my life don't the
people in my life are great and I'm so
fortunate to have people who are
actually supportive of everything that
I'm doing but nobody's telling me Evan
you suck you could be doing more like
what you've done is great but I know you
could be doing a lot more and the amount
of growth that I have seen in the past
couple years I attribute exactly to the
video content that I have consumed and
made for you guys and I guarantee you
whether it's watching youtube videos
like mine whether it's reading a book a
day you know whether it's consuming just
content that inspires you in a regular
basis if you were doing that if you made
it a daily habit a daily practice to
consume content whether that's from a
book or video or friends or conferences
or meet ups whatever the thing is that
gets you feeling like you could do more
you could be greater you could
accomplish
your things right if you did that on a
daily basis whatever the thing that
makes you feel bold on a daily basis I
guarantee you that your life will be
unrecognizable from where you are in one
year from today your change will be
insane and so there's that famous quote
that says you are the direct result of
the five people that you spend the most
time with right and that's very true if
you look at the five people who you
spend the most time with they're
probably around the same spot that you
are and so the hack that sheet the
shortcut to get to a better place is
through aspirational mentors it's
through books it's through videos and so
I would encourage you strongly to really
do it audit of how you are spending your
time what kind of content information
you are consuming on a regular basis and
is that contributing to you on tapping
the inner potential that you have to go
off and do amazing things and if not and
let's change it if you want to join the
best live 30 challenge click the link
right here below me or if you want more
videos on how to boost your reading
habits check out the playlist right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you soon